let's turn this brightness out a little
bit shall we great first off we're gonna
start with a few of my favorite videos
this week the first video is actually a
commercial for Kmart
I hate these big gas prices sounds like
you could use some big-ass baby I'd love
some video saying it first started with
this video which was the I my pants
Billy you can ship your pants too
I can't wait I just shipped my pants and
it's very convenient this video I
actually found because of comedy week it
was on the front page and I even lost my
mind the whole concept of this channel
is conversations with my two-year-old
but acted out not in the two-year-old
but a grown man acting as the child she
can talk to me whenever she wants to
talk to me no she's not your wife she's
the princess the only disappointment is
this channel only has one video this is
the only video like I want more those of
you guys that haven't heard the new Xbox
one it was revealed this past week I was
there that guys here it is look
super excited because you guys know it
in a huge Xbox fan it has been eight
years since Xbox has released a new
console I thought really long time what
are the big highlights judging by this
video there's maybe crack up laughing
watch Stevie Stevie TV in TV remote TV
experience not only the Xbox gonna be a
new gaming console but it's also gonna
be an entire media you can connect your
King boy you can tell your xbox that you
want to watch a show and guess what the
Xbox will do it will put the show on for
you want to spec the difference
I don't really Skype with anyone but if
you did or you want to guess what you
can Skype break from couch eight core
CPU a gigabytes of RAM 500 gigabyte hard
drive plus blu-ray which was the only
reason that I ever bought a PlayStation
to begin with I'm going tell you how
many times I've actually watched a
blu-ray DVD maybe once one thing that I
thought was actually pretty cool with
the new Kinect not only can it see in
the dark
complete blackness it'll see you but it
will also be able to detect your
heartbeats I'm a huge fan of fitness
stands so this is gonna be amazing to
see how they actually integrate
heartbeat into not only fitness games
but just games in general a scary game
hey I'm scared my heart rate raising
there's still a lot of questions
regarding not only the Xbox about the
PlayStation 4 III is right around the
corner so we will get all of those
answers but I am excited about though if
I'm sorry I says all I want to talk
about right now the Call of Duty ghosts
they did a side-by-side comparison of
warfare 3 and Call of Duty ghosts the
arms and mw3 were beautiful at the time
but the new engine allows significantly
increased texture resolution and
exponentially higher poly count I'm
looking forward to seeing all of your
PlayStation Xbox debates so leave those
in the comments and no fighting let's
look let's be nice next what I wanted to
show you guys this new camera I got hold
on this camera it looks like a little
square nugget my other vlogging camera
broke so and some that went back to get
fixed in the meantime I bought this one
as
replacement I've actually been eyeing
this up for quite some time because you
can connect this to Wi-Fi you can post
videos those photos directly from the
camera to the Internet now if that's not
enough while you're connected to Wi-Fi
you can also send those photos directly
to your phone
I haven't actually posting photos that
I've taken here and posting them on
Instagram from my phone magic no this is
not a sponsored video and no Canon has
never sent me anything
neither examples so just let's just
clarify that okay the crazy thing about
this camera is it only has three buttons
there's an on and off button there's a
share button and there's a preview
button to take a picture you push right
here on this ring my only complaint why
doesn't this flip up like this oh so I
could get really great food angle shots
you'll want to clip the other way I've
been perfect for filming yourself and
vlogging you didn't really think this
through too well did you
canon next time can you please call me
to consult because I've been vlogging
with your cameras ever I've got a lot to
say next time is styling fashion hmm not
really feeling too fashionable today but
I did go and get a really bright orange
manicure it's summertime so let's let's
show those colorful nails and some what
other fashion news I've got some new IJ
army t-shirts if you are not a member of
the IJ army you can join the IJ army
mailing list I put a link in the
description and if you'd like to get
t-shirts check them out you can check on
that casino's Richard calm we also have
a European store so make sure you click
on that I'm gonna go I love you guys
we're all doing it freakin amazing and I
will see you